capitalism you see
the whole theory of marxism was that
capitalism would collapse
when there was no longer a large portion
of the world in extreme poverty that
could have raw materials extracted from
it that the
master class society those who can the
capitalists those who control the means
of production would then fabricate
into
finished material which would be sold
back to the undeveloped world and they
marx may have been right
in but the problem is he didn't
recognize with the facility of
capitalism to create new conditions for
itself so i see the space thing is the
greatest lease on life for capitalism
that there is without space we're headed
for a zero growth steady state highly
regulated
highly uh
a leveling where those with much have
less those with less have more when it's
all over nobody has as much as they feel
they should have
and uh you know i had a flirtation with
marxism in my youth but i it's just
they've had now
50 years to get it together and they
have to produce something more appealing
than what looks like an abandoned air
base
i just can't this barracks society these
grey-faced people with shopping bags i
can't handle that
and
you know of course
capitalism and america is horrible of
course uh you know
transsexual ballet troops hawking
coca-cola is a different approach to
things
big civilizations are messy the every
big civilization has had things in it
which most people probably thought was a
pain in the neck the whole nature of big
civilizations is tolerance you know so
that we can have
create anarchists all kinds of sexual
politics all kinds of art movements it's
a messy business anybody who who doesn't
want a messy society is some kind of
crypto fascist of some sort
so does that answer the thing about
a lot of people don't like the space
thing i it is the most resistant idea
because first of all it's associated
with the military-industrial complex and
all these crew-cutted
types
and
but
and the new age you know the
glorification of the earth
and the wish to nurture the earth and
all these things but i just think that
the people who are into those things
have not really
seriously taken a look at the issues we
can't have a garden
planet
with
the billions of people that we have
people who wanted a steady state garden
planet should have gotten their
political program in place around
sixteen hundred that was probably about
the last moment where that ever stood a
chance we have to find solutions all
this zero growth steady state thing even
if we achieve zero growth still the
aspirations of the third world are so
great that there isn't enough glass
plastic and heavy metal in the planet to
give everyone on earth the standard of
living of the american middle class
so
a way has to be found out i think that
if you are an earth
nurturer if you identify
with that you should be a fanatical
supporter of
space colonization because we have to
get
the toxic aspects of humanness off this
planet a reasonable goal would be that
by 2050 no manufacturing be allowed on
the surface
you know let's just keep the surface as
a residential area and
and do all this other stuff somewhere
else
you know it's like the relationship
of a child
come full term to its mother
i mean a birth is taking place there's
no question about it we are going to
become
this star dwelling angel
and
it is the earth is everything it formed
us we arose here but nevertheless you
can't stay in the cradle forever
and we have to move out we have to
accept that we're going to change this
is the major thing you know we need to
find out what humanness is
in essence
so that we can hang on to it because
everything is going to become possible
to change
we can already change our sex change our
mind it won't be long before you can
change your body
are we monkeys how well does the monkey
overcoat fit the angel mind do we want
to shed it once we understand dna we
will be free to design ourselves what do
we want to be
the mushroom may once have been a monkey
that chose then a different evolutionary
strategy and designed itself into itself
you know we will eventually acquire the
ability to become what we
dream of being and so we need really to
explore our dreams because they're the
maps of our future i think this has
always been true you know the dream is
the carrot that's leading history
forward and now we add to that the
psychedelic experience which is like the
waking dream it's like the dream
emerging into the light of consciousness
for inspection it means now that we must
be very near the goal the veils are
being cast aside at a greater and
greater rate
and the psychedelic state anticipates
this the whole thing mercilead says
somewhere i think in miss dreams and
mysteries he's talking about magical
flight in shamanism and in the same
motif in yoga and he says something like
whatever we may think of the objectivity
of these phenomena the image of
self-transcendent flight speaks volumes
about the ontology of the human soul
meaning
we want to fly
that's what we want to do and here some
people have suggested that history is
the story of the search for powered
flight
you know first one thing and then
another because we always understood
that somehow to fly meant to conquer
space and to fly meant finally to leave
the planet
[Music]
you